The Joe Rogan Experience the hardest of
the hard
the gangsters of La I'll be riding down
the Sunset Boulevard
and out here under the bridge coming out
of a low rider and it is the toughest
scariest most you know looked at looking
dudes just melting with under the bridge
I'm like okay
that was that was a day well spent in a
writing that song do you always close
with that song
what do you guys mix up uh we mix it up
and but yeah it's a meaningful tune it
has the test of time when you guys close
with it the other night I was like yeah
you kind of have to
uh I owe a lot of that to Rick Rubin
that song
he's amazing isn't he he's all right
what a trip he's all right he's such an
unusual for a beginner he's pretty good
so we were writing a blood sugar Sex
Magic you know and I was at the time we
would just spend our days together it
was a lot less busy
he wasn't a dad and we would just hang
all day
what are you working on show me the
songs you're writing
because he's producing a record and I
showed him all the way you know sexy
songs heavy funky songs
it's like okay that's good we can work
on that he's like anything else in the
book
just a poem that really isn't a song I
mean it has a Melody but I don't think
it's for us
well let me hear it I was like ah it's
kind of embarrassing it's a little
sentimental
love to hear it
is Rick because Rick knows like
there's no rules you want the thing
that's not expected
so I sang him under the bridge and he
was like that's your best song I was
like ah it's just a poem
bring it into the voice show them the
song
so with that Rick's push
you know for the the counter-intuitive
sensitive Guy song
we might have never had a chance to
write that there's some people in the
world that are magic yeah I love Rick
and he is Magic he's a magic person yeah
he he has like when you're talking to
him like he has
a sense of ignoring the [ __ ] and
just tuning into the magic
it's a very and you could tell when
you're talking to him it's not it's not
nonsense it's like a science almost it's
like an understanding of what it is and
he just follows that that frequency just
he chases it down
yeah he's tuned into that yeah he's very
good at that
he's another person if you look at his
Origins
it's no accident that he ended up
being the person that he is
single child
out in the suburbs of New York City I
think Long Beach
Long Island
and he had an aunt
very cerebral boy already just like very
smart kid
but living a boring culture-free life of
the island
and he had an aunt who lived in
Manhattan who loved her nephew and every
weekend or every other weekend whatever
he would go spend with her and she was
cultured she was like we're going to the
Opera we're going to the symphony we're
going to the museum
we're gonna go see all this different
stuff and Rick was amazed by the music
and the art and the culture that she was
sharing with him that he wasn't getting
in his home life
and he just started
tapping into the magic
and dedicating himself in a way that led
to him starting his record company when
he was in the
NY NYU dorms but it wasn't an accident
like he got fed the raw materials as a
kid and it opened up his dream
and I think probably also being a single
kid you're not influenced by your
siblings either
so you have a chance to sort of be who
you actually are
less influence he would get on a bus and
go
200 miles to see James Brown when James
Brown was still on tour by himself and
he would get there five hours early they
were like you gotta wait in the parking
lot because doors don't open for five
hours as a kid by himself to go see
James Brown I was like yeah you're
qualified just out of appreciation not
even thinking there was a career
involved in that that's what's so crazy
about his story yeah there was no career
to be that guy nope no he invented a
career yeah there is no there is no
light there was no future in hip-hop no
people looked down upon it they thought
it wasn't even music yes
call us back when you have some music
they would say isn't that hilarious yeah
he was telling me the whole story of the
connection between Aerosmith and Run DMC
about people like what the [ __ ] are you
doing you're like ruining Aerosmith and
then the hip-hop people like what the
[ __ ] are you doing you're putting
hip-hop together with rock the [ __ ] is
that and then meanwhile it's like oh my
God you just United Two Worlds yeah he
United Two Worlds and opened up a whole
new realm of possibility for music and
he just did it by following magic yeah
yeah
so I've I met him in maybe 1985
and we were
flailing I was lost in a [ __ ] sea of
drug addiction just
too thin to win that start huh how'd
that start
I'll tell you but first I got to show
the little tidbit
so I was basically a junkie but still
showing up to work from time to time
which was the basement of the Emi uh
Studios on Sunset Boulevard they gave us
a little basement to rehearse him they
had signed us
but we were going nowhere very slowly
couldn't get out of our own way
and but we were still making a buzz
there was still something
exciting about us that caught people's
attention and it caught Rick rubin's
attention
and he was with the Beastie Boys and
they were exploding with success and and
greatness writing incredible music
and so Rick brought the Beastie Boys to
our dingy little recording or rehearsal
spot and he sat there and we rehearsed
while they watched they're in these
little dirty couches watching us and we
went through our
songs
and Rick Steuben said we're gonna go now
I was like okay do we do we talk again
what's going on
we'll get back to you didn't see him for
years
and years and years went by
eventually I got clean and he came back
and said let's make a record
but I said what happened that day you
came and we played and you disappeared
and I never talked to you again he's
like
I thought somebody was going to get
murdered in that rehearsal space I
thought somebody was going to die I had
to leave that's how dark we had become
that's how dark I had become is he was
afraid someone was going to die
and it was time to leave murdered that's
what he said he's like you guys were
terrifying you were scary
it felt like somebody was gonna die we
had to go
when you look back on those times do you
understand how he thought that not
exactly
but
everybody has their own perception and
and there was darkness in the room
when you're following that lifestyle
there's definitely a instead of a
magical energy there's a very
discernible dark energy
yeah but I didn't realize it was that
dangerous
he was scared
how did you get
on the road the drug Road
well I think the road was already in me
from birth
uh combination of
predisposed to addiction
physically
and then emotionally
I developed the tendencies that I needed
to squash some of the noise
spiritually a little depleted
so I started smoking weed and loved it
it was a very fun
and at the time subversive thing to be a
part of like today it's pretty damn
common
but then it was very Outlaw as a as a
young teenage boy
and years went by and there was no
problem and then I started introducing
narcotics at a pretty young age and
really had nothing to say about anymore
I was like the Caboose of a train
just going wherever the hell that train
said to go
it was interesting and it was exciting
but it was also painful as hell it was
just like in the end this is a life of
suffering
um fortunately
you know my my destiny was meant to
survive that and um
you know it isn't really events or
advice or anything that
gives you the window to step out of that
but it's it's a little gift from the
cosmos
that just makes you look at yourself and
say I'm gonna give you a chance I'm
gonna give you an opportunity
to put in the work to get better if if
you so choose if not
carry on
what was the narcotic of choice
of choice I would have to say uh the
combination of heroin and cocaine was
at that moment
at that point in time do you remember
what you started with of those two yeah
I probably did the cocaine shortly
before the heroin but right around the
same time very young age
you need to do it because it was the
thing that people around you did was it
just exciting was it rebellious like
what was it was it a part of rock and
roll it had nothing to do with rock and
roll or trying to impress or put on a
pretense it was happening around me in
my world it was exciting and dangerous
like everyone's afraid of that you know
I think I'll do that thing that just the
word scares people
but it was also a
a way of checking out
like in the same way that you know one
person will sit down at a bar and have
some beers and just not stop
yeah that allergic reaction to the
sensation of
finding your medicine right I had that
reaction
like I felt whole
by putting these things in me until I
had to pay the toll
you know it's like you steal from Peter
you got to pay Paul the next day and
it's a terrible paycheck to write
terrible paycheck to write I could only
imagine yeah
yeah it was
it was finding the thing that that I
thought was going to make me well
but really it was just killing me
and how long were we on that road for
well I think I was
27 the first time
that I was able to put in the work and
get sober
and then I went
to my young 30s and kind of forgot where
I came from and forgot the the process
of maintaining it's like
do you get physically fit it's not going
to be for life you gotta yeah show up
yeah or anything else you know you're
crap your craft yeah you put it down it
fades so I'd put down the craft of
sobriety and it opened an opportunity
and I ended up going back out there for
a bunch of years like five years
which was even worse because now I knew
that there was a solution
and I was just ignoring it
so there was nothing fun about it and
then
the window came back and I had another
chance to uh commit to sobriety and I
did and that was 21 years ago how did
you get sober the first time
um so in a way my my best friend died
which did not instigate sobriety did he
die from drugs he did
um but it definitely
destroyed me emotionally
but I continued to use after he died
and then I got to the point where I
could not turn off the noise with drugs
and alcohol literally flooding my body
with the substance and still wide awake
so I was not getting the desired effect
I was like this is terrible like I'm
putting all this poison in me and I'm
still here
and uh I called up a friend and rehabs
were not a thing at that time
I called up a sober friend and I was
like
what are those rehab things I gotta find
one
he's like the only one I know of is very
expensive 10 grand
which in the 80s for a struggling
musician was I was like I have 10 grand
that's exactly how much money I have
and I spent it I gave my last 10 grand
my only 10 grand ever
to a rehab and I went and I checked in
and uh there was 30 dope fiends in the
room of all walks of life
but all with the common sickness
and the counselor said I'm looking at 30
of you
and
stats wise one of you is going to get
sober out of here wow and I was like get
out the way because I'm taking that spot
I was such a little competitive yeah
it's an eagle Maniac you're just like
right I am taking that right please you
know the rest of you can go back to
where you came from only one out of 30.
that's what he said to us and there was
like a guy from the SWAT team that was
professional athlete that was just every
variety of person in there I was like
I'll take it
but then I realized there's a process to
it and there's a being of service aspect
to it and there's a
becoming humble aspect to it all and
that was the beginning of me taking many
years to go from being a complete idiot
to only a partial idiot